les robots volent notre travail 74% des
Français en sont convaincus 54% pense
même que l'IA est un danger pour
l'humanité une révolution technologique
qui menacerait 36 millions d'emplois
alors demain tout ce chômage quand on
dit la science la peur d'être remplacé
n'est pas nouvelle une douzaine
d'individus masqués pénètre dans une
musique avec des marteaux il détruisent
les machines une par une puis
disparaissent dans la nuit le patron
aurait dû s'y attendent il avait reçu
une lettre de menace démantèle ta
fabrique ou l'armée du général lutte
rendra visite des dizaines d'autres vous
me connaitre le même sort l'Angleterre
s'embrase les plus fortunés paniques le
scénario du prochain film Joker non
c'est l'histoire des ludithes en 1811
deux ans de guerre civile plusieurs
millions d'euros de dégâts les autorités
dépassées envoient les militaires une
centaine d'arrestations 24 pendus pour
l'exemple un jeune ado dans le Lot le
général Lude lui demeure introuvable et
pour cause il n'a jamais existé le
mouvement n'avait en réalité aucun chef
tout sera semblé par une peur commune
être remplacé par la machine beaucoup
d'articles sur l'intelligence
artificielle en parle se demande si le
même destin nous attend les parallèles
sont nombreux guerres en Europe
inflation galopant et remplacement des
emplois qualifiés aujourd'hui ce sont
les professions intellectuelles qui
s'inquiètent à l'époque c'était les
tendeurs de draps des artisans capables
de manière avec précision et doigtée un
énorme ciseau un mètre 30 60 kg imaginez
les armoires à glace c'est bien payé 3
jours de travail par semaine une bonne
planque quand la révolte ludique éclate
ça fait déjà une bonne cinquantaine
d'années que l'industrialisation est en
marche les tendeurs n'avaient rien fait
pour la stopper persuadé d'être
irremplaçable jusqu'à l'arrivée d'une
première machine divisant par de la main
d'oeuvre puis par 10 en 1815 avant
d'éradiquer totalement la profession
cordonnier couturier forgeron tous sont
obligés de rejoindre les usines 16
heures par jour pour des salaires de
misère partout en Europe les révoltes
ouvrières éclatent contre les machines
ça participera même à l'indépendance de
la Belgique mais ça ne servira à rien le
regret technique ne peut jamais être
arrêté ce qui peut être changé par
contre c'est les décisions politiques la
machine est neutre en soi ce n'est pas
elle qui a fait baisser les salaires les
conditions de travail des ouvriers au
contraire elle aurait dû l'améliorer si
à cette époque on a vu le temps et le
recul nécessaire pour comprendre ses
implications prenons un exemple vous
avez une petite boutique et vous croulez
sous les papiers vous passez votre temps
à remplir des formulaires un oubli et
c'est la punition la technologie peut
améliorer vos conditions de travail
comme celle d'axonaute qui sponsorise
cette vidéo un logiciel de gestion mais
c'est quoi cette OP bah non aujourd'hui
on est beaucoup à avoir une petite
entreprise tu gagnes des soucis sur
Internet et artisans tu fais des
missions freelance tu as forcément de
l'administratif relou j'ai passé
tellement de nuit blanche à faire ça
plutôt que de me concentrer sur ce qui
apporte de la valeur axonaute c'est tous
les outils dont tu as besoin en un seul
endroit et pas que raconta ou de la
gestion tu peux aussi gérer tes clients
tes salariés tes finances tes factures
tas de réseau tout ce que tu faisais
dans un groupe Excel tu peux la voir
dans une interface jolie sur PC sur
mobile tout ça est automatisé avec des
documents conformes et légaux pas
étonnant qu'axonaute et une note de 4,67
sur trust pilot c'est un Banger situé
ton propre patron en plus c'est pas cher
avec une offre promotionnelle de moins
50 % et un mois d'essai gratuit gagner
du temps c'est gagner de l'argent alors
clique sur le lien en description a-t-on
déjà connu des chômages technologiques
de masse ce gros caillou a un secret
c'est le premier outil de l'histoire
vieux de 3,3 millions d'années il
servait à des singes évoluer pour
découper la viande et les eaux accédant
ainsi à la moelle nutritive besoin de
moins de bras pour récolter plus de
calories ça a été un énorme avantage
évolutif depuis la course à la
technologie n'a jamais cessé l'arc
réduit le nombre de chasseurs la queue
les porteurs d'eau la poulie les
ouvriers de chantier ne parlons pas de
la roue non seulement elle révolutionne
le transport et la construction mais
elle a permis d'économiser des milliers
de bras en l'accouplant avec la force de
l'eau l'une des plus vieilles usines du
monde se trouve à Barbegal 16 rois aube
monté en série 32 meules la force de 100
chevaux capables de produire jusqu'à 28
tonnes de farine par jour est-ce que ça
a provoqué un mouvement anti
technologique et bien ça aurait pu la
plus vieille grève du monde date de 3000
ans à Rome on a eu des moments de masque
comme les Sécession klebis tous les
travailleurs qui abandonnent la ville
pour laisser les nobles se débrouiller
tout seul mais pour éviter de fâcher le
peuple on distribue des aides et
ralentit l'innovation un empereur aurait
ainsi acheté une invention pour
l'interdire Kelly rownie que ça soit
encore l'Italie qui soit le premier pays
à interdire chaque GPT parce que c'est
du populisme mal placé non seulement ça
sert à rien on n'empêche jamais le
progrès mais c'est oublier le concept de
destruction créatrice prenons l'exemple
du transport Paris - Marseille à cheval
8 jours en train quelques heures les
dizaines de milliers de cochers et
d'aubergistes sur le chemin n'ont plus
d'utilité mais étrangement sacré plus
d'emplois cheminots mécano mineur
sidérurgistes chef de gare boutiquier le
taux de chômage anglais est alors au
plus bas le consensus scientifique est
clair la machine ne vole pas le travail
elle libère des bras augmente la
richesse produite et créée de nouveaux
besoins c'est déjà le cas au 15e siècle
l'imprimerie m'est au chômage les 200
copistes de Londres mais vu que
maintenant plein de gens veulent lire 20
000 postes d'imprimeurs sont créés dans
la foulée mais qu'est-ce qui se
passerait si on arrivait à la limite de
nos nouveaux besoins c'est déjà arrivé
dans l'histoire causant la destruction
de 97 % des jobs il y a de siècles 18,2
millions de Français vivaient de
l'agriculture 600 000 aujourd'hui la
mécanisation l'engrais et le
regroupement des terres ont fait plus
que tripler la productivité sans créer
d'emploi chiffres à l'écran simplement
parce que nous estomac et les surfaces
agricoles ont une limite on ne peut pas
manger plus et on ne peut pas faire
grossir la planète alors les bras se
sont massivement déplacés vers
l'industrie puis rebelote dans les
années 70 les usines fermes c'est la fin
des Trente Glorieuses les bras se sont
encore déplacés vers les services cette
fois le problème c'est qu'après ça il y
a plus rien lia sera-t-elle la première
révolution à nous mettre tous au chômage
jusqu'ici
bien l'aller le taux de chômage français
est relativement bas après tout ça cache
malheureusement plusieurs réalités les
entreprises sous perfusion 160 milliards
d'aides par an 15% de Job précaires 10
millions de personnes sous le seuil de
pauvreté a-t-on atteint la limite de nos
besoins beaucoup le pensent même Elon
Musk appelle à ralentir le développement
de l'IA une situation jamais vue résumé
par ce journaliste du New York Times
nous n'avons aucune leçon du passé pour
nous rassurer jamais l'humanité n'a
connu un tel élan une telle vibration
une telle dislocation des transitions
aussi brutales que celles qui nous
attendent ça fait peur hein sauf que
cette citation date de 1933 elle a
presque 100 ans on s'inquiétait alors de
l'électrification des usines en fait
l'IA crée déjà des emplois j'ai moi-même
quitté mon poste de professeur à
l'université pour devenir data scientist
accomplitrice j'essaye de trouver de
nouveaux usages à l'intelligence
artificielle pour l'intégrer au système
existant chaque métier aura besoin
d'intégrer Sonia tout comme il a fallu
créer le site web et la page Facebook de
la coiffeuse en bas de chez toi imaginez
tous les cerveaux qu'il faudra c'est
déjà 384 milliards d'investissements
dans le monde l'industrie est en
première ligne les usines des GO veulent
utiliser l'IA pour supprimer les
derniers humains des chaînes de
production ça reste une activité
dangereuse pas très épanouissante et
puis tout le monde s'en dit gagner 8000
salariés début de 1000 20000
actuellement même le médical s'y
intéresse avec le trait médiatique
Watson capable de synthétiser les
dossiers des patients pour simplifier
les diagnostics mais là où elle semble
avoir le plus de potentiel c'est dans
l'administratif le commerce et la banque
on lui confie la cybersécurité la lutte
anti blanchiment ou la détection des
fraudes pour l'instant il y a dans les
entreprises est encore balbutiante on
manque de personnels qualifiés ça coûte
cher pour des gains relativement
restreints 93% des grands groupes s'y
intéressent mais 46% seulement
l'utilisent comme toute nouvelle
technologie elle a son lot de problèmes
sur l'éthique la sécurité ou
l'environnement imaginez qu'un biais
discriminants conduisent l'IA à refuser
les prêts aux roues parce qu'avec toutes
ces datas c'est la décision optimale à
prendre et bien la figurez-vous que
c'est ce qui s'est passé avec facebook
add l'algorithme a conclu que les femmes
étaient moins intéressées par les pubs
d'offres d'emploi donc leur en a moins
proposé ce qui aggravent encore plus le
problème comme quand il y a de la police
a déterminer qu'il y avait plus de
crimes dans certains quartiers donc la
police y a plus souvent patrouillée donc
trouver plus de crimes et la machine
s'emballe et c'est logique liane prédit
pas l'avenir elle reproduit le passé en
amplifiant les billets du présent par
nature et fiante plutôt que progressiste
une data mal utilisé peut-être
dangereuse côté écologique le bilan est
plus mitigé qu'on peut le lire dans la
presse oui ça coûte plus cher en CO2
qu'une requête Google mais pour peu que
vous consultiez 4 à 5 sites pour avoir
votre réponse que le coût d'entraînement
duia soit réparti entre plusieurs
utilisateurs alors ça devient moins
polluant que le web classique surtout si
on peut réutiliser la chaleur des
datacenters tout ça c'est des problèmes
qu'on va devoir résoudre et mon travail
c'est de coordonner tout ça c'est 8
pôles que vous voyez ce sont autant de
besoins à venir pour garantir une IA de
confiance une loi européenne est déjà en
préparation visant à éviter les dérives
si en 2030 certains prédisent que 50%
des métiers actuels seront détruits
n'est-ce pas parce que 85% des métiers
du futur n' pas encore et puis dans
chaque activité tu n'as pas qu'une seule
tâche lia va juste nous décharger des
plus répétitives par exemple un
commercial n'aura plus besoin de
répondre aux mail donc d'attendre des
heures pour la réponse ou de faire
attention à l'orthographe mais on aura
toujours besoin de lui ne serait-ce que
pour serrer la main des clients pareil
dans les studios d'animation plus besoin
de centaines de gras de papier qui
recopie des frames intermédiaires toute
la journée tu sais les moments moches
quand tu fais pause on pourra travailler
davantage les scènes et faciliter la vie
des dessinateurs qui ont souvent des
rythmes intenables toute la société va
gagner en confort et monter en qualité
ça sera ça le nouveau besoin l'exigence
les seuls qui se font remplacer sont
ceux qui n'auront pas intégré l'IA alors
routine de travail les plus tranquilles
seront les métiers ou beaucoup de tâches
ne sont pas encore automatisables
construction aide aux personnes âgées
soin ou agent d'accueil une entreprise
japonaise avait pourtant annoncé leur
faim il y a 10 ans même la mairie de
Paris en avait fait la promotion et
c'est un échec les clients préférant un
contact humain car oui ça sera ça le
second besoin on va donner beaucoup plus
de valeur à les choses la création
d'objets uniques fait avec les mains un
poème écrit en direct avec le cœur la
vibration d'une voix qu'on entendra à
quelques mètres de nous la ruralité
deviendra plus facile à dire sans les
problèmes de désert médicaux et scolaire
l'opportunité de faire émerger une
agriculture bio de meilleures qualités
plus respectueuse avec beaucoup de
nouveaux emplois la clé il y a aussi un
modèle ou nous n'arrivons pas à
transformer le travail ou une élite
d'ingénieur règne sur 90% de chômeurs ça
fait un bon scénario dystopique mais
l'histoire nous a montré que ce n'était
pas comme ça que l'humain fonctionnait
je suis personnellement confiant dans
l'avenir ça va bien se passer à
condition bien sûr de ne pas faire
l'erreur qui a conduit au ludith à
savoir profiter d'un gain de
productivité pour creuser des inégalités
sacrées de la défiance et de la violence
envers le progrès parce que oui un
moment faudra se poser la question du
soudeur de 55 ans dans la Creuse qui a
peu de chance de devenir informaticien à
Paris que faire de lui attendre son
départ pour supprimer son poste le
former même si c'est efficace le mettre
en retrait anticipée le jeté sans plus
de considération à nos citoyens et à
nous pouvoir public d'étudier
sérieusement la question ce n'est pas la
fin du travail c'est sa renaissance
[Musique]